alors Inès oh vous êtes né homme et à
l'âge de 18 ans vous avez subi
l'opération pour changer de sexe voilà
bravo parce qu'il faut avoir des
couilles pour le enfin
et maintenant voici mon stagiaire Tom
villa
qu'est-ce qui t'arrive c'est quoi cette
musique là je voulais vous révéler
quelque chose Thierry voilà qu'est-ce
qui se passe ça va peut-être vous
surprendre mais toi aussi tu
je peux plus supporter votre parfum
voilà je vous dis c'est c'est quoi ces
gasoil ou 95
les rois de la nuit parisienne des
années 80
Thierry Ardisson et Peter et Sloane
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Paul Gaultier alors je sais pas
lequel a le plus de dossiers sur l'autre
en tout cas ce qui s'est passé au Palace
doit rester dans les chiottes du palace
très important
Jean-Paul Gaultier bonsoir alors bon si
vous êtes venus ce soir pour me proposer
de défiler avec vous ça serait grand
plaisir par contre je préfère vous
prévenir je marche comme un canard et si
j'ai des talons ça sera plus Daisy que 4
mots
en tout cas bravo Jean-Paul
contrairement à Madonna 40 ans de
carrière et pas une ride ça peut
s'applaudir très fort
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que j'aime bien chez Jean-Paul
c'est qui surprend toujours dans ses
défilés Loana vous aviez défilé pour lui
il y a une dizaine d'années il y a 3 ans
c'était Nabilla donc en fait on dit que
les candidats de la téléréalité ils sont
cons non il faut juste défiler pour JPG
quand même mais c'est vrai non
mais alors Jean-Paul vous êtes ami avec
tout le monde si vous avez un répertoire
c'est le Ouzoud tenez on va faire un
petit test vous avez le numéro de
Madonna ou pas ouais ok Catherine
Deneuve Nabilla
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir alors donc Thierry la femme à
barbe c'est fait le nain beg c'est fait
le premier homme qui a fait du visage
c'est fait le 24 sexuel c'est bon alors
tenez Inès je vous donne la petite carte
de fidélité Salut les Terriens d'accord
vous êtes ici chez
chez vous
vous
revenez vraiment quand vous voulez un
quai Royal est offert alors moi ce que
je vous propose Thierry pour la semaine
prochaine j'ai une chinoise qui s'est
fait griffer des nichons dans le dos
ça sert à rien mais au moins elle peut
dormir sur le ventre et sinon j'ai un
Syrien qui cherche à rester dans son
pays mais il faut pas tarder à l'inviter
parce que ça sent le roussi quand même
très drôle
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes né homme et à l'âge de 18 ans
vous avez subi l'opération pour changer
de sexe voilà bravo parce qu'il faut
avoir des couilles pour le enfin
il faut des frites
Loana bonsoir alors c'est le grand
retour de louana vous êtes aminci vous
avez changé de look en politique on
appelle ça faire une François Hollande
alors n'allez pas nous décevoir s'il
vous plaît vraiment
[Applaudissements]
Loana Loana c'est la première star issue
de la téléréalité c'est à dire que vous
êtes la première qui a gagné l'argent en
foutant rien de ces journées mais en
l'assument totalement et on le montrant
à tout le monde quand même love story et
puis bon on revient il y a eu l'histoire
de la piscine mais moi je m'en fous de
ce qui s'est passé mais ce qui me choque
c'est pas ce que vous avez fait de moi
je peux comprendre moi tout seul mais ce
qui m'a choqué c'est que personne n'ait
changé l'eau franchement je trouve ça
dégueulasse
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
inestro Inès rau quand on passe sur la
table d'opération avant un changement de
sexe est-ce que c'est vrai que le
chirurgien comme dans Qui veut gagner
des millions il vous demande si c'est
votre dernier mot
Jean-Paul Gaultier c'est vrai que quand
vous avez proposé un Nabilla d'être
votre égérie avant d'accepter elle a
taper le mot égérie sur google pour
vérifier
absolument pas absolument absolument pas
et pour terminer Loana alors Loana
pendant quelques temps vous avez eu les
cheveux roses cette équipe coiffeur mon
petit poney
[Applaudissements]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu